hi
this video is about how i set up the 750
grain drill
to drill kern's a perennial wheatgrass
kernsa is a pretty fluffy
and a tiny grain it's going to get
drilled a half inch deep on seven and a
half inch centers
and i've got 24 acres
and there's 411 pounds of
seed which is 288 pounds of pure live
seed so that comes out to 17 pounds an
acre
that's a pretty tiny amount to put down
and i and i need to be pretty accurate
about this because i don't have a lot of
way to get extra seeds so i want to be
as precise as possible this drill
doesn't do very well on low seed amounts
per acre
there's an adjustment here
it goes from 0 to 60 which moves the
seed cups and opens them and closes them
i ended up
the final setting on this side was at 14
and the other side was 16 in order to
balance both sides
without the half speed gears that would
have been down at
not even half it would have been six or
seven and it's really hard to meter it
out
so the first thing i did with the half
speed gears once i had that in i blocked
off
all of the seed cups except for
four
here is one of them and i put a bag over
each of the four there's one there one
there and then there's two more on the
other side
and then what i would do
at least to get a rough sense of it
first i used the wheat
settings in the book and that was
they suggested i should be down at four
or five but i ended up being at eight or
nine initially
and my initial
uh run on this i ended up with
eight seven eight point seven pounds per
acre so what i would do i would take the
weight of the four bags net
and would weigh them on the scale and i
would i would net them out in here
and
multiply by six there's six
there's 24 rows on this i'm only
monitoring four i'm collecting from four
so multiply that by six
and the way i covered the distance at
first was to jack up this rear wheel
underneath here you got to get on this
piece of tube
jack it up and then the book tells you
how many
revolutions equal one acre in this case
it's 363.
i ended up doing 36 and a third spinning
it by hand as fast as i could to
replicate the speed i'd be traveling
i did that two or three times and and
actually i did it once twice
and ended up
first with
i was getting closer and closer i can't
see what this one is here but i ended up
at 14.9 then i bumped it up a little bit
and then finally what i ended up doing
was going out in the field
with all four of these things bagged and
each time you have to reinitialize it
to to make sure there's enough seed in
the tube you know so you're getting a
full shot from the time you start at
zero till the time you end up
but i went out into the field and with
the gps i just
made a line and then i came back and i
monitored that distance
and at the real time speed that i was
going and i'm happy with where
that ends up i meant according to this
15.75 pounds per acre and i'd rather be
a little bit under than over
i've also got a loop monitor in here
that
supposedly will keep an eye on things
for me
it seems like a little bit of overkill
but
i wanted to
do a good job with the rate on this
because there's such a light amount
going down
[Music]
jacking it up and spinning is no fun
i ended up using a stubby bottle jack
and there's a um
this piece of tube right under here was
right under that tip ideally i would
like to been on the
on the
round tube housing but there was no way
to get under there and cup that
i found one video with a guy used a um
automotive jack with that little cup on
it and he went right under that
that spot right there
so well i'll do the bottle jack on that
it seemed to do okay a few times that i
had it up in the air
and the other thing too with these
drills of course you've got to have
the arm has got to be in the ground
in order for this mechanism to engage so
that these these rocker shafts have got
to be rotated down so i just ended up
opening up the the pressure valve and
letting the valves sink down that causes
the shaft back there that black shaft to
rotate 45 degrees and then when that
rotates there's an arm that's bolted to
it right there that comes up here to
this clutch i think it's a what i call
clutch with those two offset plates in
it and then that rotates those so they
line up and then
this outer shaft here driven by a chain
from that back wheel
will actually
connect with this shaft over here which
then goes back inside this outer shaft
over to this gearbox and it goes from
down here
i'll show you all the work i did i i
the solution i came up with for this
it's just ugly you see i had to cut that
corner out there
because
these are the half speed gears but in
order to get this gear off
that's on that shaft i mentioned that's
got two sides to it that
are you know the internal and external
sleeve so that's being driven over here
by that shaft when those clutch plates
engage and then that drives this bigger
gear which in turn that shaft right
there
i don't think point got too blurry
am i going too fast
well that's the shaft here
the upper shaft for the seat cups
i don't know what's going on with this
camera
i guess i got a time limit or a memory
limit or something
well you're going to get an
impressionistic view thanks for uh
paying attention hopefully this helps
somebody if they got to do kearns uh but
you're going to see i had to chop that
hole there because that spur gear want
me to get it off and just come straight
out
and i ended up using an air hammer to
drive that roll pin out that's in there
that's holding it on the shaft
with a roll pin uh
chisel rope in uh
air hammer
but all in all looking good and here it
is first of september should drill this
and it'll dry out in a day or so
bye for now